In this recitation
we will apply some
of the ideas from Moneyball
to data from the National
Basketball Association--
that is, the NBA.
So the first thing we'll
do is read in the data
and learn about it.
The data we have is located
in the file NBA_train
and contains data from all
teams in season since 1980,
except for ones with
less than 82 games.
So I'll read this in
to the variable NBA,
NBA = read.csv("NBA_train.csv").
OK.
So we've read it in.
And let's explore it
a little bit using
the str command, str(NBA).
All right.
So this is our data frame.
We have 835 observations
of 20 variables.
Let's take a look at what
some of these variables are.
SeasonEnd is the year
the season ended.
Team is the name of the team.
And playoffs is a binary
variable for whether or not
a team made it to the
playoffs that year.
If they made it to the playoffs
it's a 1, if not it's a 0.
W stands for the number
of regular season wins.
PTS stands for points scored
during the regular season.
oppPTS stands for
opponent points
scored during the
regular season.
And then we've got quite
a few variables that
have the variable name
and then the same variable
with an 'A' afterwards.
So we've got FG and FGA, X2P,
X2PA, X3P, X3PA, FT, and FTA.
So what this notation
is, is it means
if there is an 'A' it means
the number that were attempted.
And if not it means the
number that we're successful.
So for example FG is the number
of successful field goals,
including two and
three pointers.
Whereas FGA is the number
of field goal attempts.
So this also contains the number
of unsuccessful field goals.
So FGA will always be a
bigger number than FG.
The next pair is
for two pointers.
The number of successful
two pointers and the number
attempted.
The pair after that, right down
here is for three pointers,
the number successful
and the number attempted.
And the next pair
is for free throws,
the number successful
and the number attempted.
Now you'll notice, actually,
that the two pointer and three
pointer variables have
an 'X' in front of them.
Well, this isn't because we had
an 'X' in the original data.
In fact, if you were
to open up the csv
file of the original data, it
would just say, 2P and 2PA,
and, 3P and 3PA, without
the 'X' in front.
The reason there's
an 'X' in front of it
is because when
we load it into R,
R doesn't like it when a
variable begins with a number.
So if a variable
begins with a number
it will put an 'X'
in front of it.
This is fine.
It's just something
we need to be
mindful of when we're
dealing with variables in R.
So moving on to the
rest of our variables.
We've got ORB and DRB.
These are offensive
and defensive rebounds.
AST stands for assists.
STL for steals.
BLK stands for blocks.
And TOV stands for turnovers.
Don't worry if you're
not a basketball expert
and don't understand exactly
the difference between each
of these variables.
But we just wanted
to familiarize you
with some common basketball
statistics that are recorded.
And explain the
labeling notation
that we use in our data.
We'll go on to use these
variables in the next video.